The moral presuppositions of a culture are instantiated in its stories.
They're not instantiated then it's explicit philosophy.
There might be a layer of explicit philosophy and of course there is in the West
in a layer of explicit law.
But underneath that there are stories and there isn't anything under the stories
except maybe haven,
you know,
and that's so implicit.
It doesn't even actually count.
It's not a cognitive operation.
And so this is the story.
These are the stories that are underneath our culture.
And so there better be something to them.
That's what we hope.
And but more importantly maybe we shouldn't toss them away without knowing what
they mean.
Because if we tossed them away then we're throwing everything that we depend on
a way as far as I can tell.
And we will,
we will pay for it.
We'll pay for it individually because we'll be weak.
You know?
Cause if you're not firm in your convictions,
then someone else who's from their convictions can,
you're their puppet like instantly.
And then you're also the puppet of your own doubts,
right?
Because unless you have convictions,
you're going to generate doubts like mad cause everyone does.
And then the doubts when,
and you'll be paralyzed because there'll be,
you know,
50% of you moving forward and 50% of you frozen,
stiff and that'll be enough just to lodge you in place.
And so,
okay,
so there's a psychologist [inaudible] of the idea of leadership,
which is very important.
And then it's associated with the idea of character,
logical development.
And it's associated with the idea of struggle,
not happiness.
And it's also associated with this Abrahamic idea,
which I really liked.
And which was something that's been very useful to me as a consequence of doing
these lectures.
Because remember at the beginning of the Abrahamic stories,
Abraham's like a stay at home guy,
right?
He's like the guy who's 40 years old living in his,
in his,
in his mother's basement and God says like,
get,
get the hell out of there.
You know,
get out in the world where you belong.
Go do something difficult because what you're doing isn't acceptable.
And you know,
the first thing he does is go somewhere,
there's a terrible famine,
and then he goes somewhere.
There's a tyranny.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's pretty funny.
He follows God's call and it's not like sweetness and light and paradise
immediately.
It's nothing like that.
It's,
it's instantaneous combat,
you know,
of the most difficult kind.